[Music]
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm with my good friends
and whereabouts are away we are in
bishop auckland
and how much did you buy this house for
we bought it for 24 and a half thousand
so they bought it for 24 and a half
thousand pounds
let's find out what happened next who's
living in here
and how much the refurb cost and how
much it's worth now
welcome to our humble apple
terrace house yeah nice it's decent
when you bought it was it in really bad
disrepair or was it okay
it was okay it was okay but it was not
really livable
in that state yeah so we had to turn it
around okay
yeah so just like like did you have to
plaster it
uh no you just did painting i think it
was cream inside and some of those
just needed uh what you call the filling
okay
so we just did cosmetic uh so like
minimal
how long has there been someone living
here since january
is very happy yeah so when we came
he thought maybe we're selling the house
like you guys why would you sell the
house no
no we're not saying we love him yeah
he loves it he wants to stay here for
three years
oh that's good
it was kind of new ish i think when we
took on the property so
yeah we didn't we left the kitchen we
just thought let's just save some pounds
and
yeah yeah it's quite a big house it is
yes
yeah just upstairs
have you been enjoying the wednesday
night cool oh yeah i love them yeah
i love them good good and you you bought
this cash
you bought your cash 24 000. 24 000.
yeah and then you spent how much on the
reverb 2
000 pounds 2 yeah and you know how it
revalued
three value and uh we're pulling out
37.55
yeah so the refund what was the
evaluation
50 000. did you hear that
50 000. that's incredible
yeah i still can't believe it
absolutely incredible
yeah that's like one of the juiciest
deals yeah
and how much is the 10 how much is the
tenant paying 37.75
375 and what are the mortgage payments
75
74 pounds actually 20
[Music]
437
oh jeez yeah
yeah yeah so yeah they lent you 37 000
for 10 years
yeah yeah
that's so good i know pulled all the
money out
i know i'm going down to you somewhere
oh wow
and your courage by actually doing it
because it took some courage yeah he did
yeah
but yeah definitely andrew you're happy
here
are you happy here yes it's a nice house
i like it yeah
good so you're paying three seven five
yeah
and how long have you been here three
months and how long do you plan to stay
a couple years at least yeah good good
well they they talk only good things
about you
so they said that when we were coming
you said you're not selling oh yeah
but uh no we're just here we just do it
uh you know just to film it
he knows he's a good landlady she's very
nice yes very good she fixes things when
they're broken she does she doesn't
looks after the blind she does yeah
good excellent thanks very much what's
the power skirt again
the l14 yeah hsx
all right yes what is it
you bought it november 25th yeah
so they bought it november 25th for 24
and a half thousand pounds
okay and then you had a loan against it
so they bought it for 24 and a half
literally a few months ago november
2020
and then just got a loan
from t-side money for 37 and a half
which means you pulled out all of your
money
yeah plus
12 and a half minus your refurb say 10
grand
yeah that's ridiculous
so basically they got paid ten thousand
pounds to have the house
you never look at it that way but yeah
this is crazy
this is gonna be the best deal we're
doing an awards we're doing an award
tonight
yeah normally every year we do an awards
night for our academy members
um and this i think this would win an
award this house oh really
i think it would so look
so they borrowed 37 grand but they but
they bought it for 24 and a half
they're paying 2.38 fixed
the valuation with fee was free
and the monthly payments are 74 pound a
month
but the tenant upstairs pays 375
which means you're left with a few
hundred pounds a month
and it was not only a free house but
they got paid effectively 10 grand
to have it and we got a cash back as
well from the
lender 300 pounds cash back from the
lender yeah
oh thank you samuel i should be doing
that to you definitely
it's all because of the knowledge from
you wow i'm really
really happy i've got another
opportunity all right um
for development so it's a plot of land
nice with the planning permission to
build a two-bed detached house
you guys are moving up now yeah yeah
definitely right yeah
so how much was the crack so the
number's
quite good yeah and they sell avoid
a lot of money for it and negotiate it
to 45k
okay so you've agreed the price you've
agreed the price and
it's been accepted already yeah
so 45 grand for the land and it's got
plan permission to build a two bed house
yeah detached okay and how much do you
know have you had builders go out and
quote
for the for the build i built the first
filter and this ate
uh 60k so i'm waiting for two more
okay what would what would the end value
be up once the build is finished maybe
170k
i think i'll back that yeah i think i'll
back that
i think you guys have got something
special about you
like nausea first she does some training
and she gets two rental rents
yes and basically become financially
free of rent to rent
then you go and buy this which is like
the best ever
brr deal now you've got a development
deal yes
i know it says the people around us i
think
being around you on a weekly basis i'm
learning quite a lot
yeah oh man i'm using blah blah blah
she's big shawna right no i speaking
devilish
i mean i'm really happy i'm so so happy
the land in all seriousness though uh if
you send me the details
i will um i will i will potentially fund
that
really yeah oh thank you so much yeah we
could do a joint venture
i can't guarantee i need to look at it
yes but
but potentially yeah because that sounds
really good and everything you touch
seems to turn to gold
yeah i think it's the people that i
surround myself around yeah and the fact
that you do everything you take action
but you take
education yeah you do everything right
and
so yeah brill are you excited
i'm so excited i'm so positive
and you're renting rents how are they
going they're going well
they're going well i'm i'm looking for
another one yeah
yeah i'm also looking into getting to
service accommodation
hopefully quite soon yeah good you guys
are going to be millionaires soon and
just know it i'll feel it
i believe everything yeah you're well
you're on your way
and the fact that you've done this on
this small deal yeah you can do it again
but just add zeros on the end yes and
the bigger
the bigger the deal the easier it is
anyway yeah you know
how did you how long did it take to get
this little refurb done
well five weeks five weeks ago coming
down every weekend i used to come
mostly by myself and then did you do the
work yeah we did
we did together yeah i did maybe that's
why it was so cheap yeah because you did
it
yeah so all the flooring i did all the
carpets did you yeah i learned to do
them from our previous
uh rental range i was charged 500 pounds
and i said deliver the cup is 120 and i
went and bought the tools
for 60 pounds i watched youtube and i
did it myself oh
man so this is the fifth house i've done
so now i do all the carpets yeah i'm
learning to do barbie but i do all these
[ __ ]
in carpets and special couple
my handyman power power couple power
team
that's the drawing the planning yeah
but it's not the technical plannings yet
so yeah
due to meters how big is it is it like
maybe what 60 square meters or something
do you know
how big the house is 103. 130 it's not a
small house
no it's 103 square meters because it
looks like it'd be quite small here but
that's quite a big house yeah because
this house is probably
70. i would say
wow yeah
i'm very interested what we could do as
well
is um is once you've done that one
then do a little estate
you know what i'm saying but why because
i've got five houses yeah i've actually
seen
um they've got a few plots of land
um in the area i think there is one
where you can build
three houses where did you where did you
find it from
online online
crazy but it's about i think it's about
knowing what to look for because there's
thousands of houses and pieces of land
online but when you know
most people can't value the end value
know what it's going to cost to build
but when you know how to do that yeah
yeah yeah i've actually got a comparable
all
right
let me see if i can show it to you this
is like one second where do you live
next up okay yes so this is 160
yeah yeah this is a new girl it's kind
of newish
but yeah
what do you know what year it was built
what year i'm not sure
it will be worth 170 then it must spread
yeah because if this is 116 was build
kind of reason
there's a brand new yeah build yeah
amazing well i'm gonna head back to
london
but i have to say hats off to you guys
man massive congrats
i think you'll agree they've done
remarkably well big things from these
people
big things coming before we go final
words of advice to anyone watching this
may be thinking how can i do the same
thing
how can i get into property what would
you say yeah i would say
surround yourselves with people that are
very supportive and who wants to see you
win
and attend every training if you feel
there is a strategy that
resonate with you go for further
training and
implement what you've learned you shall
make it
yeah i mean i totally agree and i think
taking action is the first step
uh getting ideas but when you take
action complement it with training
that's the best formula yeah there we go
guys you heard it here first
every day i put out videos like this
every day of people winning doing deals
making money becoming financially free
building their portfolio and if so many
other people can do it i really believe
you can do it too do you guys believe me
oh yeah
you can do it too so what do you need to
do well firstly join me at the property
investors crash course it's
free and it's where it all starts did
you guys attend the crash course
yes 2019. and how was it it was
awesome yeah before the crash course did
you have any experience of property
investing
not at all no idea i led at the crush
course and
implemented what i learned yeah here i
am today
yeah so there we go you can come as well
for free no excuses
no excuses i'll leave a link in the
description below also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel you can do that
right here
and if you want to hear nozzy's full
story on winners on a wednesday
you can watch the whole video up here
and check that out
get books on the crash course see you
soon thanks guys